now back to our breaking news a former
soldier who claims that his hands were
wet and that his gun slipped when he
shot and killed a man in 1988 has been
found guilty of manslaughter David
Holden shot Aiden mcanespie at a county
Tyrone border checkpoint in Northern
Ireland during the troubles well let's
bring in our senior Island correspondent
David Blevins who's in Belfast for us
this ruling's been a long time coming
David tell us more
yes David Holden was an 18 year old
member of the Grenadier guards on duty
at okner cloy in County Tyrone when 23
year old Aiden magnesby was fatally shot
in the back after passing through a
security checkpoint in 1998. Mr Holden
who's Now 52 admitted that the shots had
been discharged from a machine gun in
his hands but he said it had been fired
by accident that his hands were wet and
that his finger had only been on the
trigger for a number of seconds at the
court during this trial heard that he
had previously identified Mr mconesby as
a person of interest to the security
forces and therefore the prosecution
made the point that of all the places
where those shots could have ricocheted
it was quite unbelievable that they
could by accident have struck the very
person who was under surveillance by Mr
Holden at the time some really damning
words from the judge in the last half
hour Mr Justice O'Hara said the evidence
that Mr Holden gave during his trial was
entirely unconvincing that it was
incoherent that he did not believe him
that he had created a false account of
what happened and he said he was beyond
any reasonable doubt criminally culpable
and found him guilty of manslaughter he
is the first former British soldier to
have been convicted of a historical
offense in Northern Ireland since the
1998 Good Friday agreement six veterans
to date have been charged two of those
cases collapsed another two were halted
and in the case of one soldier he died
while on trial so this really is a
significant finding and of course it
comes at the time when there is much
debate about the government's attempt to
bring forward legislation to effectively
end the prosecution of soldiers for
historical offenses in Northern Ireland
victims on all sides have fiercely
opposed that legislation because of
course it doesn't just grant the fact to
amnesty to former soldiers but to former
terrorists and the government just
yesterday said it would bring forward
amendments to address some of those
concerns but they're still not
acceptable to victims so this former
Soldier has been found guilty of
manslaughter back in 1990 and back in
1988 and he will come before the court
again in a few weeks time for sentencing